Hello Freak bitches. So
I think there's that. Uh,
but then there's also look, you know,
like the Colin Kaepernick thing,
I think that probably costs
a lot of ratings for the NFL.
Did they do that? They're the, yeah. There
was that poll that came out that said,
I think of the 12% of people who said
that they were not watching NFL games last
year,
28% of that 12% said that the Kaepernick
national anthem thing was the reason.
Yeah.
I mean it's some small percentage
probably embolden them. They probably
liked it and they wanted to watch it more.
This is fascinating about the
cultural breakdown of the country.
Basically white people hate didn't black
people loved it. This is a visitor.
This is how the polls where it's like
72% of black people thought it was great
and like an equal percentage of white
people thought that it was just terrible.
And which is it?
Which is a fascinating look at that
sort of how race relations work in the
country at large.
Is it?
It's actually one of the reasons I think
that ESPN has been losing writings.
Like I used to watch ESPN
religiously and now I,
all I want is to just watch my sports
and not be bothered with the politics.
Right.
Cause I say I do that during the day.
It's a pet peeve of mine that every time
I turn on ESPN I have to hear a lecture
about Caitlyn Jenner or about black
lives matter. It's like shot up.
Caitlin Jenner hasn't even
been athletically relevant
for since before I was
born.
I was born in 1984.
Well the Caitlyn Jenner piece,
when they did it for ESPN,
and I don't know if this is true or not,
but the word was that her getting athlete
of the year or whatever the award was
like the hero of the Year award euro,
uh,
was directly tied to the exclusive
interview with Diane Sawyer.
That makes sense. They sold the two
of them together as a package deal,
which I buy 100%. If you
don't, if you don't come on,
Liz works. If that's the case where she
came from, she's a fucking car dash in.
Okay. She's a giant
car dash. Yeah, that's,
and that's what she is now known
as I'm saying she, you know, yeah.
You're saying she, I would say very
politically correct. Yeah. I'm not, um,
but the video where they circled her
house and she was like moving in the
shadows behind the drapes. Did you
ever see that? No. It was wonderful.
It was wonderful.
She made,
it was like the first time she was
revealing herself as this woman.
So they're circling her house.
She's this Gloria's house and like,
it looks like it's in Malibu or somewhere
where they're circling the house and
it's in the hills with a
helicopter like filming. I,
it's like fucking high production value
shit. This isn't just like, Hey, you know,
we met with Caitlin and home Kaitlyn.
Tell us your troubles. You know,
like Kristen back,
the former navy seal who just sits
down very reasonably and says,
this just feels better for me.
This is who I am, right? No, no.
There was like curtains and shadows and
who's mysterious and and then she starts
talking. I was like, like Whoa, God.
And then there was a weird,
weird is part where she said she got
surgery but it doesn't make me any.
I was,
it wasn't like I was any less of a man
or less of a woman before the surgery.
Well, this is the case is about gender.
Right. Well then why get the surgery?
That was like, this is, well the, there,
there are a lot of questions as to
the logic of all of this. I get you.
You Call Caitlyn Jenner. She, Caitlyn
is a biological man. So sorry,
get triggered.
Sorry to break this to some of the,
all the people who listen to your show.
Caitlyn Jenner is,
I had a tweet this week.
All the people that are listening
that probably agree with you. Yeah,
that's a good book.
Good amount.
Do the number one retweeted tweet I have
ever had, had a hundred and I tweeted,
I think a day of going, it has
120,000 likes and it's, it was,
there was a headline from CNN that said
transgender man gives birth to a trans.
What it was it as transgender man,
uh,
assigned the female sex at birth
gives birth to a healthy baby boy.
And so I tweeted, woman gives birth
to boy, right, because it's a woman.
I mean this like that's not a
headline. I'm sorry. Like I'm just,
because of the woman believes she's a man,
doesn't make her a man.
Like biology still exists.
Sex still exists.
If you want to say she's a woman
who feels like a man, that's fine.
If you want to say that,
I don't even care if she
gets hormone treatments or
if she wants to have surgery.
Like it's a free country,
what the hell you want.
But when you start
insisting that I use that,
I just throw biology out the window.
I don't understand why that's any better
than I is a religious person saying
every time you say something you have
to mention God, right? Like, well,
I don't have the right to do that
to you. Like, well that's idiotic.
Are you fascinated by it? Are you
fascinated by the transgender? The,
I'm fascinated by just
society's obsession with it.
That's a good way of saying it.
There's not just a, an obsession.
It's,
it's compulsory and it's rabid.
So I think that there's a couple of things
that are going on. One is that it's,
it's very dark, but I think that
there is an element of like,
this is different and we get to, we get
to revel in the, in the weirdness of it.
But we're gonna pretend that it's all
about the civil rights of it. Right?
We're going to feel like special
because we're, we're, we're,
cause we're on their side watching Caitlyn
Jenner because it's a curiosity and
because it's weird and entertaining,
we're doing it because we're
on Caitlyn Jenner's side.
But their good about forever. Yeah. Right.
I mean Renee Richards was a trans person.
It's happened throughout history.
I mean there's, there's,
what was I reading a couple
of days ago about a Roman,
like there was something
about reports of a,
some trans soldier in the Roman army,
you know,
boring and thousand years
ago it's gotta be, if it's,
if exists now and it's existed
before it was popular. Yeah.
I mean there's gotta be a lot of people
that turn trans now just because it's
exciting. Oh, there it is. Right there.
A Trans Soldier in ancient Roman arm
that would of course that it wouldn't be,
wouldn't be surprising. I
mean, not shocked. No chart.
I mean it's a condition.
I mean the DSN called the gender identity
disorder and then they called the
gender dysphoria. It's, it's
a condition. I mean like,
I'm not saying conditions for you,
but that in a lot of people's mind
is labeling it somehow or a negative.
Well,
I mean it is highly linked to suicidality.
There's a 40% lifetime suicide rate for
people who have this particular gender
disorder. That seems to me
not to be like great positive.
Whether or not they transition, whether
or not the transition. Yeah. I mean,
and it doesn't, I don't care if you
transition to what you want to do, but,
but the idea that, that we as an entire
society, you have to redefine what sex is.
And we have to blind
ourselves to a biology is,
this is something I'm not willing to do.
I think that it's actually
damaging to kids, particularly,
I'm more than willing to
call her a she and chain,
but you can only change your name.
One,
I'm willing to call Caitlyn Jenner,
Caitlyn Jenner.
I'm not willing to call Caitlyn Jenner
issue because you can't change your sex
and change your name. Right? Can you
change it into whatever you want?
I don't care. But you can't, she,
Caitlyn Jenner is not a chicken.
Caitlyn Jenner is not a woman. Caitlin
Jenner is a man, a biological man.
And if a man lost his penis and it, and
Eh, you know, in a, in a tragic accident,
it wouldn't make him a woman.
And if he were born with a high
doses of estrogen in his bloodstream,
he would also not be a
woman. Right? You already,
you are determined by our chromosomes
and they're not even talking about
intersex people.
Like intersex is an actual status
intersects is a biological status,
but this nonsense that if you Joe Rogan
decide tomorrow that you are a woman,
no surgeries nor homeowner and
the homeowner, nothing. You just,
tomorrow you wake up and not not decide,
but you feel like a woman,
then you have always been a woman.
We must treat you as a woman.
You don't have to change anything
about yourself for us to even determine
whether you're a woman. We
just like, no, I'm sorry. No,
I mean like I had mental illness.
I had a, I had a grandfather I got,
I got so much shit for this,
but I had,
this is not me being unsympathetic to
people who suffer from a condition that is
really tragic and obviously harms
people. You know? In terms of the, again,
the rates of suicide and depression
are astounding. My grandfather was a,
was a bipolar schizophrenia and it would
have not been good for him or my family
if people had said to him, Nate, you're
right, the radio is talking to you, Nate,
you're right. The curtains
are talking to you. He went,
did they put them in a mental hospital?
They gave him with the m and then he
was better and he could actually live a
normal,
relatively happy life.
There's no good treatment
for gender identity disorder,
gender dysphoria or whatever
you want to call it,
but to suggest that it is a condition
that doesn't require treatment there.
Really, it's just that you're actually
brain female. Again, this is a scientific,
there's no scientific evidence
to back this whatsoever.
Even these studies that have
been done talking about,
there's a female brain and a male brain.
First of all,
if you say this to a feminist,
you're a sexist, right? Right.
If you say to a feminist,
there's a female brand in the male brain
and male brain works differently than
the female brain. The feminist will
look you like, how dare you? Well,
it's also one,
are you
times we are allowed to celebrate classic
definitions of female beauty when a
man embraces him when he becomes a
woman lipstick, high heels, short skirt.
This is like
not in general was it k Caitlyn Jenner
was only a woman when Caitlyn Jenner was
on the cover of Vanity Fair and
a boost da. Right, right, right.
But if he had just said, listen, I look
exactly the same as I did yesterday,
but I'm a woman. Yeah. If he got a short
haircut and dress like Billie Jean King,
right. It's, it's the reason why the,
why the media loves Laverne Cox because
Laverne Cox has had surgeries and looks
a lot like a woman. So I dunno who live
around the middle of that. The guy from,
uh, well the, the transgender
woman from orange is the new black.
I never watched that show.
I've never watched that show either,
but she's on the cover of Time magazine.
Oh.
Or He's on the cover of Time magazine.
Well,
there was the woman in that show.
Isn't that the one where the girl
who ruby row is that the girl? Yeah,
that's Laverne Cox. That's a woman or
man, that's man. I used to be a man.
It used to be a man and a woman. Now.
Very tricky. You know, it's still a man,
but transgender tipping point. How far
I'm so out of the loop. I'm old man.
I'm that old man.
Yeah,
well that was one thing.
That headline there, right?
It says America's next civil rights
front here, and that's the key.
You have a bunch of people in the United
States who are suggesting that they
want the next civil rights fight. Always
the next civil rights fight. Right.
So is it the sixth the civil rights fight,
his immigration or the civil rights
fight as gay marriage or the civil rights
fight is transgenders. Okay.
How about this? How about,
there was only one real civil rights
fight news about black people who had been
historically oppressed in the United
States for 200 year there had been slaves
who had been slaves genders.
This is correct. Okay.
The worst that Caitlyn Jenner
had experienced was being
incredibly wealthy in a,
in a high net worth suburb. This is not
to say that transgender people don't,
you know, aren't discriminated against
in some, in some areas of American life.
I'm sure that's true,
but it's also like behavior is not the
same as being born black or being born
Asian or being born with,
you know, uh, disabled. If,
if I'm a business owner and I hire you
and you're a man and you come in the next
day and you're dressed in, in a
woman's clothing saying you're a woman,
but you still have a full beard. Like
I don't see why I, as a business owner,
I'm expected to eat the cost of that,
like that just did that. It seems,
that seems bizarre to me.
Eat the cost is a great way to phrase it.
I didn't have a dog in this fight.
I didn't,
I,
I was completely open and liberal about
it until there was a case where a man
who had been a man for 30 years became
a woman for a little less than two years
and then started MMA fighting women.
Yes.
Beating the fuck out of these women and
shot and not proclaiming that he or she
used to be a man because
what is it in quotes,
it was a medical condition that I did
not need to disclose. Like that's not,
I'm fucking medical conditions.
Right.
And if you ever watch
the fights when Alan Fox,
she wasn't winning
because she was skillful.
She was fucking manhandling these women.
It was ugly horse. It was horrible.
It's like this is it. But again, it's,
it's so funny how the transgender
movement destroys the feminist movement by
living off of the,
the sort of lies that the
feminist movement problem
and get it to the feminist
movement said stupid things like women
and men equally athletic profession.
Well that's
peated very recently that there's no
biological difference in the genders and
it's all social
absolute horse shit. I
mean, I'm told, sorry.
There is no scientific
evidence to back that.
And it's particularly true with
regard to actual physical capacity.
This is just nonsense. They
just no scientific evidence,
but I'm not, yeah. Yeah.
I mean mountain of it. My favorite
study on this as you know, there was,
you remember there's that,
those commercials about like throwing
like a girl running like a girl, right?
Remember there's the feminist commercial
saying what does it to be running like
girl,
no to an adult woman and she'd be running
all girly and then they would show
little girl and she's running and it's
still a little girly but she's running,
you know like normally it's
only exactly fierce. It's,
it's only society that has forced
the little girl to run. Like when it,
first of all, I have a three year old
girl, she runs like a girl second of all.
And it's not because I'm teaching her
is that cause her mom runs cause she
doesn't write but she played with
dolls because you're a sexist pig.
It's because of that.
My,
my daughters started off liking trucks
like in the first year and I can give a
shit and then and now likes playing
with dolls and dressing up in princess
dresses. Like who cares, she's a
girl, she's always been a girl.
She will always be a girl.
Whether she likes trucks or
whether she likes you guys.
That was an issue with
one of my daughters too.
My daughter was a little worried about
her. I go, she's going to be a dyke.
She was like, no, like, what's the big
deal? You like lesbians, who cares?
I don't care. I'm like, I
do not care. And she's like,
and then she turned the
corner and then she got,
but we just let her be whatever she's in.
But she was really into
like Batman for awhile.
My daughter is in ABAP and then she
was in a wonder woman. Like, who cares?
Man Is it? But what's funny about
this is that the left kept saying,
even when I met my wife, right,
who's, who's a conservative,
and I made her more conservative
when we got married,
because that's what men tend
to do to their lives. But
she, but she, uh, you know,
we, I remember early on we had a
conversation about this and I said,
women don't throw it like men. And
she got like all offended. And I said,
but that's factually attrition. Right? But
it's, but it's insulting. It's like, no,
that's factually true.
Like I'm sorry,
like there've been studies out of a
thousand if you took a woman throwing a
baseball and then a thousand
men throwing a baseball,
the woman will throw faster. Then out
of those thousand men is in the book,
the sports gene,
the one we'll throw faster than two of
those men out of a thousand and we're not
talking about like goose Gossage here.
We're talking about,
we're talking about the
accountant from down the block.
We're talking about Paul Ryan flinging
a baseball, right? I mean that,
that's not the way this stuff works.
That was the counter that found Fox used
was that she actually lost to a woman.
She lost a woman named Ashley Evan
Smith. But what I said was, no,
this proves my point is that you're
not good. You're just a man. Well,
this was John Mcenroe got slapped all
over the lot when he said about Serena
Williams. She's great. Is
there anyone who great and all,
but if Serena Williams were competing,
he said she's the best female player ever.
And they were like, well, why not just
the best player ever? And he said,
because she's a, she's a woman. Like if
you were a man, she'd get her ass kicked.
And everyone was like, no, how dare you.
There is something called
the universal tennis ranking.
She would rank in the mid
ranks of college male players.
If you were a man and Serena Williams,
he said like five years ago now,
I never want to play with like
Andy Roddick. He'd kill me. She,
she actually did this. There was a
200th rank man in the world who she,
she wanted to just warm up with and they
played it like just a normal match for
a, he won six one six
nothing right. And he was,
and he was like ranked 200th in the world.
And the only shock was that he dropped,
he dropped a point to her. Well,
there was the issue of Renee Richards,
when Renee Richards started playing
tennis against women and kicking their ass
and he was a middling player,
best as a woman or as a man rather.
But as a woman, he was a fucking killer.
I mean, Hey, I mean this is what,
you didn't sell feminist.
It turns out the Caitlyn Jenner,
when all these hero of the year awards
and everything we met are so great that
even when we decided to be women were
better than women but a woman for six
months. But he's amazing. He's
incredible at it. He's just,
he was a natural men better
even at being women than women.
No wonder feminists are
pissed and they should be.
And this whole glossing over the,
the,
the difference between feminists who have
been claiming that women are distinct
from men and important and different
and better in certain ways.
Like I don't understand how you
hold these two simultaneous thought.
Hillary Clinton needs to be president
because we need a female president,
but also Donald Trump. If he said he
was a woman, tomorrow would be a woman.
How do you hold those
two simultaneous thought?
I always thought that in the last week
of the election of Trump thought he was
gonna lose.
He should have just declared himself a
woman and then he too could have run in
the first female president.
I would have been incredible trolling
if he just showed up on the dresser and
the entire left a woman. I'm the
best looking woman ever. I've been,
I've been voted as the best
looking woman of all time. Um,
money's great arguments
that I've got it on.
Mine wasn't even arguments,
we'll put it so many people were calling
me a bigot because of this Fallon Fox
thing. It was, it was stunning because
it was so confusing to me. I'm like,
I'm talking about defending
a biological woman like you.
These biological women,
at least two of them,
got the fuck beaten out of him by Fallon
Fox before they found out that she used
to be a man. I'm like, that's
not an issue to these people.
And so this one woman said, she's
always been a woman. And I said, okay.
She gave birth, she impregnated a
woman and got her pregnant. I go,
what about then she goes, even then
he didn't. Then she was a woman.
She was a woman.
She went and she was fucking a woman
with her deck and getting that woman
pregnant like we are in fantasy land.
It's crazy town town,
but this doesn't mean
this is what's crazy.
Like you can't just because
something's a logical,
you can't just decide that
someone's a bigot. Like you're you.
You were in a weird area.
We're talking about bone structure and
here's the crazy muscle density there.
There.
There's the crazy thing is that they
always rely on these gender reassignment
doctors to define the terms.
And it's really interesting
because I got deep, deep,
deep into the rabbit hole with this cause.
I was really shocked at how many people
were angry at me and there was one
doctor who was a board certified
endocrinologist who sort of broke it down.
She's like,
not only is the science behind this crazy,
but when you have gender reassignment
surgery, one of the big issues with men,
I'm transitioning into women,
his bone density, who she's like,
when you have gender reassignment surgery,
you're taking estrogen,
which actually preserves bone density.
She's like,
not only do they have less bone
density once they become a woman,
they might have more will because
you're preserving it like it's,
you're not going to automatically be
just like a woman in a year or so.
I don't think surgeons,
I mean I know too much about doctoring
from having spent 1000 years with my
wife's medical education to believe that
doctors have the capacity to magically
change man into a woman.
I didn't know maybe it's going to happen
one day with like CRISPR or something
like that when they start using genetic,
I mean really genetic tendencies.
Maybe Andy actually at the chromosome
this before birth, but no, I mean like no.
Once, once your, once your genes had
been defined. What's your chromosomes?
Symptoms like this is fifth grade
science people. It's fifth grade science.
What scares the shit out of me is when
you hear these stories about people
deciding that their child who's like
eight or nine days left up beyond belief.
Gary, because you can't have nine year
look, a fucking 17 year old doesn't know.
That was the thing about
the ruby rose girl.
She was saying that when she was young,
when she was a teenager,
she wanted to be a man.
She wanted to be transgender,
and that she had gone through that phase
and now she's so that she didn't do
anything
right. Well, they did.
They say that 80% of kids who experience
any sort of gender dysphoria as
children grow out of it. So when you
have a society that reinforces it,
and then in Canada, they're now
having the passing laws. Now,
let's say that if a kid says, you know,
you have a girl and the girl says,
I'm a boy and she's three,
that the government can come
into your house and take the kid.
Because obviously if,
if you,
if you don't want to humor of the kid
and get the kid treatment or surgery or,
or hormone blockers, then you're obviously
doing something wrong to the kid.
This is just, it's insane. First of all,
if anyone tried to do that with my kid,
I would meet them at the door with a
gun. I mean that, that, that this is,
this is the kind of stuff where you're
talking legit civil war. Like when,
when you say that the government can
take people's kids from them because the
government knows better than you how to
parent your kids on basic things like
are you a boy or a girl that's
going to get violent pretty quickly?
If you send someone in my door with a
gun saying I'm taking your daughter from
you because your daughter says
she's a boy at school and you,
and you're not going to take her to a
psychiatrist to start her transitioning
process.
Oh no,
but what, how did we get so far
down this rabbit hole of insanity?
And this is again,
this is not taking away the personal
choice of a 60 year old man like Bruce
Jenner who decides he wants to be a woman.
You want free country go have at it,
have a good time.
But how did we get so crazy that that
becomes an option that people aren't,
they're not paying attention to the,
the massive variables
that a child encounters,
psychological variable stress variables.
What's going on in the home,
what's happening hormonally,
what's happening psychologically,
what is happening to you and how,
how can you decide like, this is it,
you're going to,
you're going to allow this kid to make a,
like a locked down decision to begin
gender transition surgery at like nine or
10 years old hormone blockers in there
to an eight year old. Yeah. And you know,
and then they'll show you like this girl
who's like 13 who used to be a boy and
you know,
you see her act and talk and they go,
how could you imagine that
this isn't a girl? Okay.
I don't, you know, I don't
know. I don't, I don't, I don't,
I just don't know what happened.
I'm going to go with the fact that there's
a y chromosomes in every cell of that
person's body,
except ironically for some of his sperm
cells to tell me that that's probably a
boy. And, and yes,
you can block the manifestation of some
physical characteristics that does not
change the chromosomes.
And there are legitimately
Intersex people, right? I mean,
there are people who legitimately have
conditions like Kleinfelter syndrome.
I mean they're, they're like, these
are, these are actual biological things,
but if you're telling me any boy can
be a girl, no, no. The answer is no.
And it's,
that's not biologically correct.
And you're not doing any
sort of service to a child,
especially with evidence
less. I mean, you, no,
you're doing no service to a
child by bringing bye, bye.
Humoring what is obviously a mental
condition. And in mental condition,
by the way,
again,
linkedin 40% lifetime suicide rate is
higher than any other population on planet
earth by a whopping margin.
I mean,
telling kids that we are
going to force you into the,
like you express when you're five that
you think you're the sex and now at eight
we're going to transition you into this
and your suicide rate is exactly the
same as somebody who didn't do that,
right.
Where it's very similar to someone
who didn't do that and, and like,
this is somehow supposed to benefit
the person. Uh, it's just, it's,
it's beyond imagination and I think it's
cruelty. What's very strange for sure.
And as someone who doesn't
experience gender dysphoria,
I liked it. I mean when, when someone's
got some sort of an issue, whatever it is,
whether you call it,
call it an issue or a
condition or whatever the fuck
it is and I don't have it.
I try to be as, as standoffish.
I tried to be as objective.
I tried to be as as kind as possible.
This is a weird one though.
This is a weird one because it's,
it's become some sort of a fad and
any criticism of it whatsoever,
even discussion of it, you are labeled as
a, as a transphobic piece of shit. Yeah.
I think it's only weird honestly because
it's run into the weird sexual politics
that dominates in the country because
if we were to talk about Anorexia,
which is a form of body dysphoria. Yes.
All right. Or if we were to talk about,
I mean there are actual is something
body identity, integrity disorder, right?
Where people like want to lose an arm.
I we we'd be saying,
well the problem is in your brain,
it's not in your arm.
Like chopping off your arms seems a little
extreme. But if you want to do that,
like go ahead. But if you were a kid and
it's a five year old, wouldn't say, oh,
well this kid's going to suffer
with this their entire life.
Like let's just chop off their arm now.
Prevent them,
their arm from developing
like this is not [inaudible].
And to tell the entire society that this
is a positive good is a whole nother
thing. It's one thing to try and treat
people who have a disorder humanely.
It's another thing to redefine the terms
of the entire civilization as well as
biology in order to fit
that. That's, this is,
it's valuing the subject over the
objective. Science is objective.
Your feelings about who you are is
subjective. You can have those feelings,
but once you are trying to translate those
feelings into the objective standard,
we all must told by now you're encroaching
on my territory. It's not just,
it's not just you doing what
you want to do anymore. You're,
you're telling me what I have to do.
And that's a different thing, right?
Well,
no one people say that there's this 40%
suicide rate amongst transgender people.
Um, one of the arguments that I've heard
is it's because they're not accepted.
Right? I've heard this too. Yeah. Yeah.
And that if they were accepted and then
they felt themselves and they felt loved
for their true self,
then it would be just like everybody else.
And I've seen no evidence to
suggest that if, if there's,
if there is a decrease based on treatment,
then it's marginal at best. But that
it's, is it uniform? Like I would
like to know is like gender dysphoria,
is it in a similar percentile as a
anorexia or what bodybuilders get,
or what's strippers get
when they get triple f tits?
I know there's a lot to look up.
Like the anorexic suicide, right. Um,
does for you is a weird thing. You
know, it's, it's, it is that people,
there's a girl that goes to my yoga class
that's anorexic and it's so disturbing.
It's so sad. Oh, it's, it's, it's
horrifying. It's horrifying. And listen,
I'm not telling, I'm not saying that we
should mistreat people, but if again,
you're talking about an entire society
mean forced to redefine basic biological
terminology,
then like it be an adult,
like live, like live with this. I'm, I'm
happy to treat you with, uh, listen what?
I would hire a transgender person,
but I'm not going to see,
I'm not going to change what
reality is in order to humor you.
Like if you call yourself Napoleon, I'm
not going to call you Napoleon Napoleon.
I'm like,
this is not something I'm up for it.
What'd you take it into consideration?
No,
I mean when you're looking
at the still like it was,
what if someone was really good at their
job and someone else was equally good
at their job but not transgender?
Would you lean towards the not
transgender person? Cause you say,
well the transgender person,
they're dealing with a host
of psychological issues,
obviously.
Well, I mean I, I think that you
would have to think about, you know,
typical aspects of reliability.
Just the same way you would with any
other mental disorder if you need somebody
was was manic depressive,
which is super common and you have
somebody who is equally qualified.
He's not manic depressive.
You might think,
well that might have an effect on on
how they do their job. Yeah. So maybe,
I mean I, you know, I've,
I haven't had enough personal experience
with transgender people to know whether
it would impact a secretarial
job or something. Probably
not. Yeah, probably not.
But it's, but again, to pretend that
like transgenders in the military,
this seems to me like in a decision
that will be made my military people who
actually have to determine how
much does this impact the job.
And if you already have a group of people
with a 40% suicide rate who have high
levels of higher levels of instabilities,
a group not individually as a group,
and you're choosing which groups to pick
from to be on the front lines in small
units living under severe pressure
for months at a time. Yeah. Like,
is that something that,
is that what you're going to go for
or is that something where like you,
you'd have to overcome certain
presumptions in order to get there? Yeah.
Tweeted something that Kristin
Beck wrote the other day. Um, uh,
but when the military band, when
Trump, apparently there was not a real
no,
it's bullshit.
I mean base from just trying to
distract from the sessions thing.
Is that what it is? Yeah. Yeah.
I get t two minutes later he's back
to tweeting about sessions here.
This was the part about
that I didn't like,
like I actually agree that there is a
question as to whether the military should
be recruiting transgender people because
I think that the military has certain,
like it creates a bunch of questions,
not just questions about who showers
with whom, but also questions like, okay,
you have a transgender man.
Does he have to fill the female standards
of fitness or the male standards,
the standards of fitness or like
these are actual questions. Does it,
how does it work with troop cohesion?
Right?
You have a group of men and now you have
a man who's technically a man, but he's,
did you treat him as a woman?
Like does you have to carry
the same amount of stuff?
Is the guy like how does that
work exactly right. It does this,
the cost of gender transition surgery
and hormones and psychologists like does
that come into play at all here?
Would you recruit from the
anorexic community for the
military? Like that's it.
These are like real questions.
But that said,
that's why they commissioned a study
from General Maddis at Department of
Defense.
He was going to look into all of this
and then give a report in six months and
Trump just sort of tweeted it out there.
I agree that,
I think that Trump's general,
you know,
his general attitude on it is probably
correct in terms of what the military is.
They're doing, what, what
it's not there to do.
But what I don't agree with is how he
did it at all because it's disrespectful
to the people in the
military who are transgender.
I mean like I wouldn't want to find out
in a tweet. I want a better rationale.
Van Two tweets and then we're back to, and
then we're back to, you know, like look,
they're doing more than,
I mean they're serving in the military.
I didn't serve in the military.
It seems like it would be pretty
hypocritical of me to say, well,
it's perfectly respectful to say in two
tweets you're out because that's the way
it is without any sort of
supporting argumentation.
And he didn't actually implement a policy.
He didn't give the policy to the Defense
Department so they could even implement
it.
The Pentagon says they're not implementing
it because they don't have a policy.
So as a PR thing,
so this a weird PR thing,
but it really stirred up people in the,
which was, I think it was designed to do.
Right. I'm sure. Either that
or he just felt like tweeting.
And I think that's what I,
I think that's what it was.
I mean he wanted to shift the conversation
and it was the funniest thing about
that is that he did it in two tweets.
In the first half of the tweet was in
consultation with my generals and my
military experts.
We have decided that we will no longer
accept Eclipsys 10 minute gap transgender
people in the military. So
there was a, there was a,
there was a story, a buzzfeed,
those kind of funny,
they went an interviewed a bunch of
people in the Pentagon and a bunch of the
people in the Pentagon or like
during that 10 minute cap,
I didn't know whether we were
going to nuclear war, what right.
Cause that first tweet we
will no longer extended.
Could've been North Korea Korea's
missile missile test programs.
So wow. Yeah. This again is evidence.
I think it's an example of even if I think
the policy is good, good policy done,
the wrong way is actually
counterproductive for the
policies that I want to see.
None like I want it laid out by Madison.
I want to lay it out
by defense department.
I want all the reasons laid out so we
can have a good discussion over it.
I don't really want just like thought
vomit on Twitter, that's just not,
I don't think it's effective.
Well it also seems that this issue is
such a hot issue and it's also an issue
that you're not really allowed to have
an opinion on other than the standard
opinion. This has always and trapped in
a man's body and this is the way it is.
And by the way, healthy this day
cardian notion that it's like a man,
it's like the,
the the sole in the machine and there was
a woman deep down for 40 years who had
three children with a man's
penis and now is now is escaping.
There's like Ghostbusters, like
uh, again goes faster. It just,
have you seen the man in England?
Was it in England knows Germany,
the man that identifies as
a six year old girl? Yes.
And so they turned them into a six
year old girl and there's this clip,
that clip of me that's going around the
Internet a fair bit when I'm talking to
a college girl about this.
And she,
she's sang like men or men can be women
and women can be men. And I said, well,
how old are you? I love that
clip. And they, come on,
why aren't you 16 she's six days. And
she, she's like baffled, like what?
And then it finally hits her and it's
like, well, you know, yeah. It's,
I think this is what's kind of
frightening about the age we live in,
is that we can't even come up with
common definitions of basic things.
How are we supposed to have
conversations with each other?
If you can't decide what a
man is or what a woman is,
or whether a scientific fact
ought to be relevant or not,
at least we could decide what was the
scientific factor, not before. And now.
It's like the subjective
has just eaten everything.
If I don't think it's a scientific fact,
it's no longer a scientific fact
and they're I no longer parameters
of the argument.
It's become about freedom.
The freedom to be your authentic
self versus biology. Yeah.
Right. And again, be be be your
authentic self. I don't give a shit.
They will do whatever you want,
like you know, more power to you.
But it is no longer about your freedom
to be our authentic self when you're
talking about either a legislation that
impacts how I run my business or how I
raise my child or your suggesting that
it is my duty to humor your authentic
self.
Like I think there are a lot of people
who do stupid crap their entire lives.
It's not my job to humor their
authentic self. I mean I'm,
I'm pro drug legalization but I've never
done drugs and I think the drugs are
stupid,
you know,
don't tell me that I have to like
cheer when somebody smokes a joint.
Like do what you want
but don't tell me that.
I have to redefine what I think is
good and bad behavior. That's silly.
Yeah.
It doesn't make any sense.
And the other thing that it became this
weird political hot point where we're
talking about bathrooms.
Yeah.
And then it become like the number one
was easy for people to sort of boil down
the argument into that. Right. Of course.
Like this. What about my children?
My children would go to the bathroom and
a man with a dress is going to come in
and he's gonna claim that
he's a identifying as a woman.
And it got to the point where so many
people were upset about it that people
were boycotting South Carolina.
Oh yeah. You know the, and, and this,
the one I thought was amazing was,
was the NCAA saying they were going to
remove the final four from North Carolina
because they passed the,
the bathroom bill right in North Carolina.
And I asked online,
okay,
so when are you going to abolish the
separate male and female divisions of the
NCAA?
My got me.
You've said that we can't have
separate male and female bathrooms were
biological males play.
And you know,
biological males go to one bathroom
and biological females go to another.
So why do you have separate divisions?
Why do you have a,
why do you have an NCAA women's division
and an NCAA men's division? Yeah.
Where does this go?
I mean eventually it boiled down.
I mean eventually it goes
to one place or another.
Like either we just say this is a step
too far. It gives me a break, you know,
science has no, or we say anyone
can be anything at any time.
A man as a woman and a woman as a
man and you know, it's in just pick.
Have you ever seen any of the videos
for people that are gender fluid?
I have seen those videos. Those
videos are fascinating. Like you said,
wake up one day and there are a
woman and the next day there are man.
And there was a guy on NPR,
on um,
radio lab on the podcast who transitions
at times of stress makes perfect sense
to me in the middle of
having a conversation. I
just switched. I'm Paul now.
I'm a man
when he's more stressed as he switched
into a woman because that'd be really
sexist, right? I mean,
I think they like it.
If he was stressed at work and he
switched into a woman and started crying,
that seems kind of sexist to me.
That's implying that women are the people
who cry at work. So that is sex also.
This raises a bunch of other
weird questions like, okay,
if you're like, there's,
there's been this, again, you wanna talk
about weird, there's been this, this,
this weird push in parts of the Trans
Community to suggest that a male who
doesn't want to have sex with a biological
male who says he's a female, is a,
is now a sexist against women.
Phobe is it trans folk? Right?
You're a bad person if you're a man who
doesn't want to have sex with a man,
a biological man, and it doesn't
make you gay to do that, right?
If you have sex with a biological man who
says he's a woman, that's straight sex,
but if you were to have sex as a
biological woman who says she's a man,
you're gay. Yeah. Kind of weird.
Really Weird.
But I have seen the arguments and the
blog posts and the tweets about men who
discriminate against trans women
who do not want to date trans women.
And people keep saying, well, it's,
it's culturally define. It's like, no,
that's called evolution. What you might
have a baby together. Correct. Correct.
It turns out that evolution wants
men to have sex with women. Like,
I'm sorry to break it to everybody,
but evolution rose relies
on human reproduction. Okay.
If you put that thing in the wrong place,
it ain't going to reproduce.
Like that's just, sorry.
I mean I don't know.
I don't know why I have to keep
apologizing for science and,
and then they say that my party is
the party of non science. Like what?
Like you're the ones who say that
two minutes before my baby is born,
it's not a baby and a man can be a woman.
But I'm anti-science. I'm just, I'm,
I'm wildly confused by this. Well, the
whole thing is wildly confusing. Um,
but it's just,
it's such a strange subject.
It's such a strange subject that's been
brought to the forefront and I think
it's about more of the moral posturing
than it is about people who actually
think this is a major issue.
I think you're absolutely right.
And I think people love to be virtuous.
They'll have to be on that side.
They live to virtue signal. How dare
you, I dare you. We're doing it.
It's the how dare you with
Dicks or lack of fake dicks,
but they don't really have a lot of fake
dicks. They don't really go that far.
They just sort of take testosterone and
see what's up. But the, the, it's just,
it's a weird facet of our society
today that is a unexpected, I mean,
you go back 2030 years and it
was an oddity and you know,
even during the Renee Richards thing,
it was,
it was more of an oddity than anything.
And think just sort of accepted.
This is why I say I think that it's,
I think that a lot of people who are
virtue signaling are still treating it as
an oddity. They just
won't admit that. Right.
I think that they're watching it
because it's a circus to them.
And I think that's actually cool.
I don't think that you should like put
people who suffer from mental illness on
the cover of magazines. I just don't,
I think that that's bad strategy.
[inaudible].